you see that girl's eyes and
instinctively I felt oh she's clutching
onto that her eyes speak volumes yes
they do
I mean I don't know her I've just I
don't even know if I've ever seen that
image and somehow she seems familiar
she's cheeky and fun and represents a
lot about you know just children the
world over really these Afghan girls are
jumping over barriers using skateboards
and this art exhibition hopes to empower
other girls both inside and outside
Afghanistan this image down there skate
girl yeah that girl that is that iconic
yes yes she's become now almost like the
new Afghan girl there was a girl with
green eyes now there's now there's her
and and she represents all the girls
we've escaped girls but also not just
scare girls but girls all around the
world in my opinion give you a bit of a
aegyo have you got to get kitted up
first okay so I can't just photographer
Jessica Fulford Dobson is displaying a
side of Afghanistan you don't usually
see with the help of the charity skaters
down yes and just the vibrance it that
inherently cuts against the narrative
here and the ideas we have yeah yeah no
we think brown is women in
but what I really love about what they
do is because all that the charity took
out that was actually just the
skateboarder they weren't taking a
skateboarding culture site here is just
a board with wheels do with it what you
want and who'd think that you put sort
of skirt and dresses on them to do this
but it works so well diner since that's
certainly on freedom yeah total freedom
and they're doing they're putting their
stamp on out or do you think this the
the the ice cream thing which is here
and there's a little speaker that they
go round if there have been any attacks
or anything and everything went very
very choirs it was when you heard the
ice cream noise there was something back
he thought okay everything's back up and
running again and like with everything
in life even though skate girls when
they have their fall in their crash
dusts themselves down get back up and
that's exactly what I had to do with the
support of Python museums the
photographs are on show in an
interactive gallery
[Music]
we're here in Doha yeah amazing
immersive immersive history yeah yeah so
it's as near as you could almost get to
attending with your adorable and and
again it's just wonderful that halogens
has been able to create this to give it
an extra speed the charity sets up
schools that the girls and boys go to in
the daytime and then after class they
put on their gear and skate she started
with Oliver Perkovic who went out there
in 2007 and he was had three skateboards
with and all the street children would
come out to watch and have a go and
obviously they were girls and boys and
they were transfixed because they
probably never seen as though as a woman
from the West suppose white yes did you
encounter any skepticism by virtue of
the fact that you're from the West and
that
Cena's exploiting I suddenly was a
little bit more aware of of actually
what I had done I think that things
could perhaps be seen in in a light that
I'm some white Western when we're going
out to get a sort of story
you know you said you're kind of giving
them a voice yes and even though it's
not a moving picture and we can't hear
their voice what does that mean to you I
mean giving them a voice how are you
giving I remember being so touched when
they said thank you for coming and
taking these pictures because we get fed
up with being seen as some victims and
you know we are strong and we want to be
able to do things for ourselves and it's
positions of power and we both like
their hand on there yeah the work in a
very lovely wedding I think it seems to
sort of cut through or address a lot of
the main societal issues of the day
which is whether it's girls education
girls at sport empowerment east and west
cultures and reminding us of what we've
all got in common and it's something
that unifies us in a world which is
often trying to just pull us apart
you